j'ai 29 ans je me nomme céline céline
étymologiquement c'est qu'est l'art est
caché je me suis caché longtemps trop
longtemps j'ai pris des postures j'ai
fait de longues études section
internationale classes préparatoires
agrégation doctorat et maîtrise de
conférence je suis reconnue pour cela
pour les milliers de pages de mémoire
écrite pour l'excellence pour la
réussite pour les tours d'ivoire
construite pour les articles rédigés
pour les conférences données et pour le
sourire timide qui a qui essaient tout
le temps je suis reconnu je ne suis pas
moi-même mais je suis reconnu pourtant
dire qu'on reconnaît quelqu'un c'est
savoir qui il est j'étais reconnu s'en
être connu je n'avais jamais les
exprimer qui j'étais mais à 29 ans tout
allait basculer petit j'avais peur de
devenir adulte je pensais qu'il arrivait
à 30 ans ce glissement vers l'âge adulte
j'ai failli ne jamais avoir 30 ans j'ai
un cancer
j'ai 29 ans je viens de soutenir ma
thèse demain je rentre en chimio
je vais partir pour deux ans de
traitement je vais enlever tous les
vêtements qui ne sont plus les miens je
vais être à nu pour ne plus me cacher
ces lignes étymologiquement sais quel
arrêt cacher je pense que cette identité
va tomber je ne veux plus me cacher à
l'hôpital une phrase dans ma tête tourne
en boucle
ouf je n'aurai plus besoin d'être
parfaite
je vais arrêter de me cacher ma bulle
commence mes cheveux tombent
je vais enfin être moi même
je vais devenir moi-même puisque je pars
dans une descente aux enfers je vais
fabriquer ma propre réalité pour ne pas
laisser la réalité atroce qui me mette à
genoux prendre mon paysage est beau les
mes rêves je vais utiliser ma réalité si
je meurs avant 30 ans est-ce que je dois
réaliser un rêve abandonnés au fond d'un
tiroir
we dance et je vais danser je vais
danser je vais danser chose je vais
danser sauvage car seule ma tête
travailler jusqu'à présent mon corps
était en sourdine il va se relever pour
crier haut et fort qui je suis il va
hurler quelle est la réalité que je me
suis fabriqué je ne vais plus me cacher
ma transformation a commencé ma
chrysalide est un cancer je sors du
cocon pour ouvrir enfin mais elles m'ont
en vol sera majestueux je serai là
deuxième étymologie de céline kayrouz
caeli le ciel je serai le ciel
l'anagramme de mon prénom sera désormais
en ciel
le médecin me l'avait dit je sais c'est
le ciel qui vous tombe sur la tête
oui c'est bien le ciel ce ciel qui me
tombe sur la tête pour l'ouvrir en grand
c'est le ciel entier que je veux devenir
quand je rentre en chimio
que les tuyaux m'envahissent que mon
corps devient faible que je vomis dans
les bassines que mes cheveux dégringole
comme une pluie sans fin je fabrique ma
réalité en faisant confiance aux
constellations que j'ai en moi en
installant des guirlandes de rêve en
laissant respirer au fond de moi tous
les horizons la force
les lucioles les coquelicots les vols
d'oiseaux le courage la lune complice
l'apaisement je suis le ciel
[Musique]
si l'info se construit une serre
nibali
obama
chris barber
[Musique]
sans un support
mais ma faute
berenguer
oh tu as there may b les chagos ti
[Musique]
scheiben choix et fine sans mourir sans
espaces
[Musique]
chaque fois
ils sont
[Musique]
oh
où
non
[Musique]
et
oh
l'oeil
non
oh
[Musique]
il
nous avons fabriqué nos réalités et nous
continuerons toujours c'est la seule
façon d'être en vie avant je me cachais
aujourd'hui nos éblouissant j'ai beau
virevolter sur tout les balançoires du
monde
non c'est un fond comme neige au soleil
j'ai un cancer mais j'avance la tête
haute
haute comme trois pommes comme une f qui
se respecte du haut de ses trois fois
dix ans je commence déjà à me relever
même si ma robe et dégueulasse tant que
les mouettes me trouve belle tout va
bien je tourne je tourne la tête
je tourne comme les éoliennes jeu
tourner de l'oeil mais j'avance en
rougir petite reine de 30 ans à la robe
s'allie aux petits pieds nus petite
princesse qui a un cancer en elle trop
généreuse pour dire non je deviens la
petite marchande d'allumettes qui
tentent de rallumer les étoiles comme
dit le poète
j'allume mais allumettes mais réalité
imaginaire
c'est ainsi ce sont mes armes celles
avec lesquelles je me bats celle que je
fabrique qu'elles soient réelles ou
imaginaires petite guerrière malades et
petites princesses à la robe en miettes
je pose mes petits pieds nus sur le
sable mou et son fragile encore mais je
sens mes racines pousser jusqu'au centre
de la terre je veux exploser de rire
volé en éclats voler de mes propres
ailes
je veux être le ciel une princesse même
enfantine à dessein les miens sont beaux
ils ne porteront plus la mort dans leurs
rondeurs dans leur ivresse
ils seront tu aurais oreilles d'amour
cercle de jeunesse je porterai deux
enfants alors que je devais être stérile
je fabrique ma réalité dans mon coeur et
elle commence alors dans mon ventre
la marchande d'allumettes en moins souri
elle a mis feu à la mort à son insu je
suis le ciel je suis en robe rouge comme
un ciel qui voit le soleil se lever je
ne me cache plus
le ciel ne se cache jamais même derrière
le brouillard je fais un avec l'univers
maintenant ma métamorphose se termine je
porte le monde dans mon ventre et
l'espoir dans mon âme maman on t'avait
dit tu es tu n'aurais pas d'enfant et du
monde a eu un garçon et une fille tu
n'iras fabriqués dans ton coeur puis
dans ton ventre tu as fabriqué ta
réalité que nous a appris à fabriquer
notre réalité
la seule chose que tu nous as dit de
fabriquer c'est l'amour on fera de notre
mieux et me voilà pourquoi nous sommes
sur terre je t'aime maman tu es klaus
kehl nous aussi nous serons le ciel avec
toi je fabriquerai ma seule réalité
celle de l'amour je vais aimer jusqu'à
l'infini hameau ergo soum j'aime donc je
suis l'amour sera l'unique réalité que
je fabriquerai chaque jour j était maman
on va construire une lgv danse et mets
toi j'aime la vie la neige
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]